in panthers upcoming or ongoing
off-season as the case may be both teams
already have made some moves or at least
have some moves lined up for when the
new league year begins on march 17. the
big question today when that clock
strikes 401 pm eastern in just
under three weeks
will
the
seattle seahawks immediately trade
russell wilson to
another team
the athletic.com
has a report
that is worth reading
and the one thing that created the the
headline for me was this back and forth
that occurred after they'd lost two
games in a row russell wilson had
seven turnovers in losses to the bills
and the rams they had a short week to
get ready for the cardinals on thursday
night the cardinals were coming off at a
hail murray game russell wilson
in a nutshell
wants to have more influence and control
over how to fix the offense he's got
ideas on how to get it back to let russ
cook it had been let russ
do anything but cook let russ crockpot
let let russ up you know i you could you
could put in 50 different words other
than cook and they ignored him and he
stormed out of the room that seems like
very uh uh un russell wilson like
behavior that caught my attention
shireen i have a feeling it caught the
attention of russell wilson's camp and
then set the stage for what came later
in the day
yeah no question about it mike when we
talk about the seahawks having been
quiet about this apparently they weren't
very quiet about this they i mean it's
obvious all of this came from the
seahawks camp and
and it looks like russell wilson has
responded to the seahawks respond but
you know he made it public right after
the season mike about how frustrated he
was with all these things he wanted a
bigger say in personnel he is frustrated
by all the hits that he's taken which is
over 40 quarterback sacks uh in in the
last eight years that's just too many
and so he's really been banged around
and the fact that they haven't won a
super bowl since his second season
haven't been there since his third
season three and five in the postseason
since then there's a lot of frustration
mike and it's all coming out right now
and the question is what does this lead
to does he i've always been in the camp
that he'll be back there for one more
year and if they don't get to the super
bowl that's probably it
but now after reading all this today i'm
not so sure he's back there next this
year mike
yeah i think this thing is working
toward a boil and my big takeaway beyond
the the factual scenario with him
storming out of the room when he tried
to get them to give him more influence
over fixing the offense
i came down to this after i read all of
it let me just say this real quickly
about this concept of the ultra long
article
i i don't want to make anybody any more
upset than ordinarily do but do the
folks who write these things realize no
one ever reads all of it and and that
should cause the people before they
submit it for publication to read back
over and see if there's a way to tighten
it up i don't think there's any
automatic praise or glory in having so
many words no one ever reads all of it
because trust me i never re you get to a
point where you shift from read to skim
mode and i'm always skimming for the
stuff that i think would make for a good
story that our audience would be
interested in but sharing whether it was
this whether it's the item the athletic
had last week on desean watson whether
it was that 10 000 word opus from espn
on the nflpa in the nfl that tracks back
10 years into topics no one cares about
i don't get it and i'm sorry to take us
off track but i just don't get it and i
don't know what motivates this because
frankly the athletic could have taken
that story today and they could have
crafted it into six seven different news
bombs that they could have dropped over
the course of three or four days
yeah no question mike
you know it's it's those long reads
people aren't reading them anymore it's
not the way it is i love writing them
there's no question about that i think
they're fun to write but when people
don't read to the end have you really
had a good use of your time and a good
use of your space and probably not i'm
with you they probably could have broken
this one up into several different bites
and posted those and they would have
gotten a lot more play out of this but
that's the athletic the way they do
things and and it's the way they've
always done things and they already have
our money so it doesn't matter they can
write as long as that's right because
they want to write but and i didn't mean
to take us off track i didn't i didn't
mean to take us off track but it just i
just it it i just i don't get it when no
one reads the whole article i don't get
it anyway what happened later this
afternoon the stuff that people do read
and digest the tweets that come out in
280 words or fewer that was where the
response came from russell wilson and it
was on the record from his age it his
agent and and i'd love to know the
sausage making process that causes
someone to say who they're going to talk
on the record to
the agent chose adam schefter and the
the the tweet from schefter with
information from mark rogers was that
number one russell wilson has not
requested a trade now we reported that a
couple of weeks ago he hasn't requested
a trade but at the same time he wants to
play for the seahawks but if he's going
to be traded here are the four teams to
which he'd accept the trade which makes
it kind of hard to sell the idea he
doesn't want to trade hey i don't want
to trade i haven't demanded a trade but
in the event they choose to trade me
cowboys raiders bears saints or the four
teams for whom i would wave my no trade
clause and what that does and i
i have reason to believe that this is
exactly what mark rogers was trying to
do
it lets those teams know you're the ones
at the table you're the ones who should
be making the offers forget about the
stories of a third of the league calling
or teams trying to get the seahawks
attention no put your best offer
together put it on the table and there's
reason for you to do it because it's
down to you you're the finalists if you
want in get in if you want out get out
but those are the four teams and go
ahead and start the bidding even though
we officially aren't requesting a trade
yeah mike that's exactly what it is if
you look at those four teams from the
seahawks standpoint i mean the raiders
obviously make the most sense to get him
out of the nfc i mean you don't want to
trade him to a team like the cowboys
that you're going to have to beat to get
the super bowl right that that probably
makes them better or the bears or the
saints any of those teams you just don't
want to do that so if they're going to
trade him and those are the only four
teams he'll go to then you start to look
at the raiders as the possibility from
the seahawks standpoint if one of those
other teams wants to offer you way way
way more than what the raiders offer you
then you get you go back to the raiders
and say all right we really want to
trade them with you to you here's what
these other teams are offering but to me
from the seahawks standpoint if you're
going to do this the raiders absolutely
make the most sense but
again
i i think it comes down mike to how do
the seahawks really feel about russell
wilson did they see him as their
long-term franchise quarterback and if
you do then you are going to have to do
some things that he wants you to do and
if you don't want to do those things
then it's obvious to me that you don't
think he is your franchise quarterback
who can lead you to multiple super bowls
so maybe it is time to move on and
listen to some of these offers
that's the litmus test if you don't view
russell wilson the way that russell
wilson views russell wilson then trade
him to a team that does because that
team is going to give you
more than what you would give someone
else for him it should get your
attention and that's where they need to
tread lightly shireen because if they
put out too much of this idea that that
maybe they don't think russell wilson is
patrick mahomes in a different uniform
that's when one of these teams may say
well you really don't view the guy as
being all that special and look that
won't matter if multiple teams come to
the table because that's the best way to
do this
what what mark rogers did on russell
wilson's behalf is what
frankly david muller guetta should do on
deshaun watson's behalf announce the
teams that watson would play for then
those teams know they're not wasting
their time if they put together an offer
and it makes sense for them to press
pause on whatever their quarterback
plans may be
the raiders intrigued me for one reason
the raiders and seahawks used to be in
the same division and they met in the
playoffs in back-to-back years including
in an afc championship game back in 83
the raiders won that game and won the
super bowl after that but you know the
raiders would make sense because even
though they say they're not trading
derek carr if an upgrade falls into
their lap they're taking it the cowboys
and sharing the cowboys are the team
that i've consistently heard for more
than a year anytime this issue comes up
of russell wilson not being thrilled
the cowboys it's the cowboys i think
he's got his eyes on the cowboys from
dallas perspective does it make any
sense to pull the plug on dak prescott
and put together a major trade package
to get russell wilson
i think russell wilson is an upgrade
over back prescott i mean you can't
argue that point because russell wilson
has the super bowl ring right and he
doesn't have the injury problem that dak
prescott has right now he signed
long term dak prescott isn't for all
those reasons i think you say absolutely
he's an upgrade on dak prescott but dak
prescott doesn't cost you anything
except money to resign if you're
confident that ankle and i don't know
how you would know that but if you're
confident that ankle is going to be okay
and he's going to be your franchise
quarterback he cost you nothing except
for money salary cap space and i know
that's important but he's not going to
cost you all those draft picks and
everything else this to me does not look
like a team that's ready to win right
now
and so how are you going to build around
that around russell wilson on your team
if you don't have all these draft picks
that's my only concern from a cowboy
standpoint is trying to get better
without the cap space and without the
draft picks to try to improve the roster
that to me is just not real good right
now aside from the weapons the weapons
are great i you know if i'm russell
wilson i want to go play
perhaps with that offensive line if they
can come back from those injuries the
the big guys we talk about tyron smith
and and zach martin but
i like the receivers too lyle collins i
forgot him but i like the receivers but
when you're looking at that defense and
other parts of that team i'm not so sure
when you're looking at the age of tyron
smith and his injury in history i'm not
so sure so
i would love to see you know what i'd
love to see and i know we can't this
would take all kinds of movement but
maybe it's
seahawks signed dak prescott and free
agency and russell wilson has traded the
cowboys i would love to see dak prescott
on the seahawks however that works out
and russell wilson on the cowboys i
think it'd be just be fun it'd be fun to
see those guys go at it for however many
years
two things first
we were two years too early for the
night that we got to sit and listen to
jerry jones and stephen jones because
tonight will be the night to be sitting
at the table at prime 47 and hearing
what they have to say about this
secondly i don't think the seahawks
touch dak prescott i think they backfill
with a rookie or someone who's a hell of
a lot cheaper because unless they can
get this trade delayed until june 2nd
they're taking a 39 million cap charge
this year for wilson in a year that has
the cap dropping to 182 183 now i think
the trade would be official after june 1
to help the seahawks and it's a it's a
demand that the seahawks easily can make
it's part of the price of admission
we're not finalizing the deal until june
2 because we want to take 13 this year
and 26 next year even then for what
prescott will cost on the open market i
think the seahawks wouldn't jump into it
and the injury issue would be a factor
as well
but look i agree with you russell
wilson's an upgrade he's older though
he's several years older but he makes it
clear he wants to play until he's 45 and
i'm telling you he has been eyeing the
cowboys for
a while at least since mike mccarthy
became the head coach of the team and i
think he understands the power of that
platform both as it relates to what it
can do for you as a player
and what it does for you not that
russell needs the help given his
personality but look at what it does for
you post playing you can just write your
own ticket into any broadcast booth you
want once you've had the star on your
helmet you can be a quarterback you can
be a tight end you can be anyone and
you're in a great position to have a job
in broadcasting michael irvin emmitt
smith had his time in broadcasting i
mean it gives you a much higher profile
and i think that's one of the reasons
why russell wilson is interested but he
also wants to be at a place shireen
where the offense runs through him
and i don't know frankly where that is
going to happen from these four teams
maybe in new orleans if they could work
it out
maybe the raiders maybe john john
gruden's so happy to have a quarterback
he can see eye to eye with and not have
to get up on a step stool to talk to he
may be thrilled to do the deal just for
that but um
look russell that that's the other thing
to consider whatever it is that russell
wants whoever trades for him had better
be ready to give it to him or you're
just inheriting the problem the seahawks
have
yeah there's no question about that mike
i would ask this too with the four teams
i mean okay does he want to win a
championship like
of those four teams i mean new orleans
is the closest but we know all the cap
problems they have they lost all their
coaches in the offseason i mean
i guess they're closest to a
championship and they saw what tampa bay
was able to do a team they beat twice in
the regular season once very
convincingly so maybe that's a team but
those other teams i mean does he upgrade
them to the point where they're super
bowl contenders
i don't know that maybe he does maybe
that's all they need is the quarterback
jump start maybe that's all chicago
needs is that quarterback they haven't
had since what sid luckman maybe but
whatever the case mike you know i i just
don't know from from those teams
perspective that that he's going to be
with what they're going to have to give
up that he's going to put them over the
top
i think the saints
are the most likely
to be rocketed towards super bowl
contention because they're already
almost there and they were almost there
for the last four years with drew brees
you put russell wilson on the field
as the quarterback and all the things he
can do and all the things that sean
payton will do to put him in a position
to be successful and all the scouring
that peyton does of all the different
ideas and trends and plays and concepts
and things to get the most out of his
players
i think that that that would be a
perfect destination from the standpoint
of winning
football games and pursuing
championships it wouldn't be easy at
first because you're following drew
brees but once you get to a super bowl
the the the fans down there will will
warm up to the idea of having russell
wilson around for 10 years or longer
assuming uh he he ends up finishing his
career with his second team but you know
it was a year year and a half ago that i
said i believe russell wilson will
finish his career with another team and
people went nuts i this has been coming
this is not a new development it's just
finally at the front burner and the
question for the seahawks is do they
deal with it now
or do they give it a year and hope that
they can fix it but either way
something is looming because within two
years mark rogers is going to want
russell wilson's next new contract and i
think the seahawks are going to be at
the point where they're not going to
want to give him that kind of money and
i think
when market value because it's 45
million now but i think once the
seahawks process all this they're going
to realize somebody's going to put an
offer on the table that is going to make
sense for them given the current state
of the relationship with russell wilson
especially now that we're hearing more
about the dirty laundry
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports